[Musique]
un des critère qui est retenu pour la
vitalité des centre-villes c'est le taux
de vacance des commerces en 2001 on
comptait 6 % de vacances de commerce en
2015 10% et maintenant on est à 14 % ça
veut dire qu'il ya de mal heureusement
les centres villes centres bourses vides
de leurs commerces sans un remplacement
en tout cas rapide c'est dans la mission
du sénat que d'évaluer les politiques
publiques et d'évaluer les textes que
nous votons au sénat et à l'assemblée
pour essayer de parfois d ajuster de
voir comment ça se passe sur le terrain
de voir si par exemple sur la
revitalisation des centres-villes des
centres bourgs où nous avons avec notre
texte sur le pacte territorial
et de revitalisation que nous avons
injecté dans la loi et l'inde ailleurs
de voir maintenant comment se passe
l'application de celle de ce texte
le commerce est avant tout le choix des
consommateurs le choix des consommateurs
ça a été cet engouement pour les grandes
surfaces à l'époque de leur installation
c'était un signe du modernisme de grande
diversité de produits la capacité
d'acheter en volume et il ya eu un
dépérissement du commerce de proximité
pour que le centre bourg où le centre
ville soit très vivant il faut que vous
ayez envie d aller si c'est juste pour
faire vos cause est peut-être allé en
périphérie seulement 6 en centre ville
ou au centre bourg la médiathèque est
ouverte le dimanche matin s'il ya des
animations s'il ya des expositions vous
avez envie d'aller en ville et de flâner
parce que on vous offre un type de
consommation que fondamentalement
différente de la consommation utile que
vous faites en périphérie ou du ou de la
livraison à domicile
quand on a des centres villes qui ont
30% de vacances derrière il ya une sorte
de désertification qui ce
secret une paupérisation aussi le
puisque il ya plus d'activité ou moins
l'activité et puis
violente dégradation du bâti